Hey, guys.
Stalling for a minute or so till everyone
logs on.
If you wouldn't mind just letting me know
if you can hear me, that'd be great.
Can you hear me?
See if that works.
Oh, awesome.
Oh, some people are saying no.
A lot of people are saying yes and no, so
my mic shows that I'm on, so you should be
able to hear me.
Worst case scenario, if you can't hear me,
what I will do is, this is prerecorded, so,
not prerecorded so we'll upload it and you
can watch it tomorrow.
Okay.
I think we're good.
Good.
I'm just going to give it a couple more minutes.
I'm just playing around with these buttons
here, I see people logging in.
We have about 2500 attendees today.
For some reason, I saw this new button, it
says 'Request' so I'm going to upload, it
says 'Invite as a speaker,' so I'm just going
to press it and see if I can invite some of
my attendees as speakers.
If you get an invitation, we'll see what happens.
Maybe I could pop you in and we can talk to
you.
We'll see if that works.
Okay, we'll just give it about 30 more seconds.
All right.
Oh, cool.
That worked.
Hey, Judy.
Judy: Hi.
Eric Berg: I just pulled you right into my
webinar here, so maybe you could help me,
you can answer any questions as we go through
this, okay?
Judy: Okay.
Thank you.
Eric Berg: Sometimes it's a little difficult
to do a seminar by yourself because you can't
see anyone but at least I see one person.
There's some other people here too, that I'm
going to invite in.
All right.
Welcome to the webinar, everyone.
We're going to get started.
This is a very vital webinar.
It's on fat burning, and exactly how fat burning
works, so you might want to take some notes,
you're going to have a lot of questions.
I will be more than happy to answer the questions
you're going to have as we go, but try to
make them brief.
It looks like Judy, Judy, could you mute your
microphone for a little bit until I pop you
in?
Cool.
Everyone able to do, because there's so many
people I don't know if it's going to affect
the pausing or not, but let's get started.
A lot of you got my emails on my recent webinar
on ketosis, and I really want to cover that
in depth.
It's a little bit complex but I'm going to
make it as simple as possible, then I'll answer
any questions that you have.
I've been doing ketosis for quite a while,
and I use it on clients that have tried everything
and nothing's worked, because a lot of people
are carb-sensitive.
I want to get into the difference paleo and
ketosis.
There's some big differences.
I also want to get into what do you eat long
term.
I think the biggest thing that comes up as
a problem is that it's a red flag, are fats
eating fats okay to eat, are they dangerous
to eat, I want to cover that as well.
I think the worst recommendation that we've
ever heard is the concept of everything in
moderation, because it allows everything in
moderation, a balance, which you'll never
get into fat burning if you do that.
That is the worst advice to tell someone,
to have a balanced diet, because that doesn't
work.
Some of the anti-ketosis practitioners out
there, almost every single one of them have
never practiced before in an actual clinical
setting.
They might do research on rats, but they don't
actually practice.
When you work with actual people, over and
over and over, over years and years, you will
find that the whole calorie in, calorie out
model does not work.
Eating less calories than you're burning does
not work, so you have to think outside the
box.
I am totally convinced that the majority of
information being put out by conventional
means is the exact opposite of what you want
to do.
I can prove that, and it just happens over
and over and over.
I'm going to pull up some slides, see if I
can do a screen share here, hopefully I can
do my screen share.
I have all these slides.
Don't tell me that I can't pull up my ... Well,
that's not good.
Okay.
Hang in there for a second.
Hmmm.
Let's see if I can do my screen share.
Why isn't that working?
I have all these great slides that I want
to cover.
Okay.
Well, we're just going to keep going here.
I'm just going to, I'm going to have to describe
some of these slides.
The first question I want to talk about is,
is ketosis safe?
Is it healthy?
I really think it's one of the healthiest
things you can do.
There's some serious research being done,
or has been done, on ketosis for all sorts
of things.
Probably the biggest thing is for brain and
neural protection of your brain.
Alzheimer's, Parkinson's, seizures, things
like that.
So the brain loves this type of fuel called
ketones, which we'll get into describing what
that is.
The state of ketosis is very good for any
type of blood sugar issues.
Diabetes, heart related issues, neurological,
cancer.
The reason why it's good for cancer is because
the cancer cell lives on sugar.
PET scans basically scan the body for certain
parts of your body that are eating up a lot
of sugar.
A cancer cell loves sugar, and if I had cancer
I would completely and utterly eliminate all
my sugars and I would have a much better chance
of surviving.
Respiratory issues, asthma, allergies, acne,
polycystic ovarian syndrome, and especially
weight loss, those are some of the health
benefits.
I'm going to probably send everyone access
to the slides so you can get all the slides.
I have research studies if you want to look
at, especially ones on cardiovascular that
basically state that when you consume dietary
saturative fats it does not in any way shape
or form increase risk of cardiovascular accidents,
or heart attacks.
That's pretty powerful stuff because that
goes exactly against what we've been brainwashed
to think.
It's very good for cognitive function and
brain function.
I'll have to kind of describe some of these
images that we're talking about.
When we're dealing with excess stubborn fat,
we're dealing with the problem of stuck energy
in the fat cell.
That is the biggest problem that we have.
I want to move beyond the conventional viewpoint
that all you have to do is balance your calories
and eat less than you're burning and you'll
lose weight.
That's absolutely not true.
Maybe if you're 18 years old, but when you
get 20, 30, 40, you don't, it doesn't work
anymore.
There's really two fuel sources.
You have the sugar fuel, and we have the fat
fuel.
Fat fuel, you really can only tap into that
when you're in ketosis.
Ketosis is a condition that the body is burning
fat, and it's actually using ketones as a
by-product of fat burning, so ketones are
a fuel source that's very similar function
to glucose, but it's a much cleaner fuel that
has three times as much energy as glucose.
The problem with running on glucose, or sugar,
is that you get high blood sugar and you get
low blood sugar.
The only, the total amount of sugar in your
blood is basically two teaspoons.
That's it.
If you ever get your blood tested and they
say you have diabetes, or you don't have diabetes,
we're going to look at these numbers.
If you're higher than 100, it's hyper-glycemia
or diabetes, if it's lower than 100 it's hypo-glycemia,
so you want to be 100.
What that 100 means is two teaspoons of sugar
in your blood at any one time.
As you do ketosis, the blood sugars will come
down a little bit, but it won't create a hypo-glycemic
state.
A lot of people oscillate from high sugars
to low sugars, all day long.
Can anyone tell me what are some of the symptoms
of high blood sugar?
Can you tell me?
Wow.
I just clicked on a button that someone sent
me.
I shouldn't have done that.
Can anyone tell me, just go ahead and type
in, what symptoms do you get when you everything
high sugar in your blood?
Okay.
Very good.
You get brain fog.
You get tired.
Blurred vision.
You get thirsty.
That's right.
Cold sweats.
Very good.
So those are some of the symptoms with hyper-glycemia.
Basically, thirsty, need to urinate often,
dry skin, hungry, blurred vision, fatigue,
brain fog.
Okay?
That's with high sugar.
Now what are the symptoms with low blood sugar?
Does anyone know?
It's called hypo-glycemia.
Very good.
That's right.
Shaky, sweating, dizziness, anxiety, irritability,
psychosis, craving for sugar, vision problems,
weak, so they really affect your cognitive
function.
Any time that sugar goes high or low, it just
messes with your physical and mental capacities.
That's why running on ketosis is very therapeutic
for your mood, for your sense of calmness.
For your overall stress.
Because the brain is very greedy.
It basically sucks up ... It's only two percent
of your whole body, but it sucks up 20 percent
of the energy.
It's constantly wanting that sugar.
You'll probably hear from some people that
the brain only runs on sugar.
Well, it only runs on sugar until you don't
give it sugar.
Then it can switch to ketosis.
So what happens is that your body will not
feed the brain ketones unless there is no
sugar in the bloodstream.
It does convert.
Here's the thing.
You have a storage of sugar.
Your sugar's mainly stored in the liver and
the muscles.
Let's talk about the muscles first.
The muscle has stored sugar, but it only is
used for the muscles.
The muscle will not give up any of its stored
sugar to the rest of the body.
It will keep it self-contained, so you really
can't use the stored sugar for your muscles
at all.
It's there to feed your muscles as its sole
purpose.
So now we're left with the liver.
The liver is storing about seven tablespoons
of sugar, enough to last for about 72 hours.
If you ate nothing or no sugar, you would
be dead in 72 hours unless there was a backup
fuel system.
That's your fat.
One thing that's cool about this eating plan
is that it really fixes a lot of symptoms
that people have with their cognitive function,
with their memory, with their mood, with anxiety.
Because when these sugars come up and down,
up and down, when you're craving and you're
hungry, that is not the way to live.
In fact there's even a stage three, Type III
diabetes, which affects the brain or memory.
Here's the thing.
I better define what I mean by diabetes.
There's two types.
Type I is where you don't have enough insulin
from that pancreas, and so the sugar goes
higher and higher, because the purpose of
insulin is to control sugar by lowering sugars,
storing in the fat.
The Type II is that insulin is being produced
but it's not being received into the receptors,
into the liver.
It's not being listened to.
It's another problem with storage of sugar.
I'm sorry, insulin.
What happens is that the sugars go high, because
the insulin's there but it's not available
to the cells.
Okay?
They're both a similar problem, but one's
more advanced.
I'm getting some interesting comments here,
that people feel great and lose a lot of weight
when they're in ketosis.
That's awesome.
Again, I will send all of you these slides.
I will just send this, because I have your
emails.
Here's the thing.
Unless you don't have any stored sugar for
over 72 hours, unless you have a good amount
of fat reserves and you know how to do this,
you won't be able to tap into fat.
So here's the big questions, and I want to
see if you guys can get this right.
Does anyone know if what the purpose of fat
is?
Can anyone tell me?
I want to see if anyone can get this correct.
This is a key question.
See if anyone knows the purpose of fat.
And Judy, why don't you put on your mike?
I can see the top of your head, Judy.
What's the purpose of fat over there?
Judy: To protect yourself.
Eric Berg: Very close.
It's definitely to protect something.
A lot of people say it's like a cushion or
an insulator and that type of thing.
Judy: Yeah.
Eric Berg: Yeah, well, that's not the primary
purpose but thank you for answering that.
If you can put your thing back on mute and
I'll come back to you in a second.
All right.
Thank you.
Energy storage, energy's protective fuel,
energy, wow, when you're doing a seminar this
big you have a lot of answers that scroll
pretty fast.
Very good.
Storage of energy.
Okay, so I have not seen one person get this
correct.
No, and this leads me to my point.
The biggest misunderstood word or subject
is basically what the purpose of fat is.
Here's the primary purpose of fat.
You guys ready for this?
All right.
I don't think you're quite ready.
Maybe we'll have to do this next month, Judy,
what do you think?
No, I'm just kidding.
We're going to do it.
I'm just playing with you.
Okay.
This is the purpose of fat.
It's a survival gland that protects against
the starvation of, what?
Does anyone know?
Sugar.
Let me say that again.
Fat's primary purpose is to protect against
the starvation of sugar.
It protects you against sugar starvation.
What does that mean?
That means that fat is a backup organ to sugar.
It backs up storage, it's a backup to sugar.
It's really, because you wouldn't last for
more than 72 hours, especially your brain,
your body gains fat in case it needs to do
that.
What does this tell us?
How does this relate to what we have to do
to get this fat off our bodies?
It means that you have to starve your body
of sugar.
Most of you already have done this, some of
you are trying to do this, a lot of people
have questions, so basically the most important
thing to know is that it's a backup organ
to sugar.
Knowing this data will now tell you what diet
would be best to be on, and if we look at
this compared to the conventional reduce your
calories and exercise more, well yeah, you're
going to reduce your calories but according
to the government you're still going to consume
65 percent of your calories in carbohydrates.
You will never tap into your fat.
Weight Watchers.
A lot of Slim Fast.
You're never going to burn fat.
Because you're lowering calories, you might
lose water weight, but I guarantee you you're
not going to lose much fat.
Here's the most important thing.
We must starve the body of sugar.
That's the bad news.
The good news is we can replace it with more
healthy fats, which is going to be very satisfying
to your body.
We'll get into exactly what that means in
a bit.
We must bring down the carbohydrates to about
five percent of our overall calories, which
comes out to about no more than 50 grams of
net carbohydrates.
Now, Judy, can you pop your mike back on?
Good.
Judy, tell me, do you know what a net carbohydrate
is?
Judy: Not really, I don't.
Eric Berg: It's very simple.
You basically look on the back of the label
and you get the total carbohydrates, then
you minus the fiber.
You minus that.
Thank you for answering me there, you can
put it back on mute.
We just take the total carbohydrates and we
minus the dietary fiber.
I want to just, I wish you could see this
slide but I'll send it to you.
I want to take broccoli, for example.
Broccoli has about 10 grams of carbohydrate,
but it has 3.8 grams of fiber.
So if you minus those two, you end up with
6.2 grams of carbohydrates.
Not that much.
You're not going to have any problems with
eating broccoli, I'll tell you that right
now.
Let's take an apple.
An apple has 25 grams of sugar and it has
4.4 grams of fiber.
That means it's 20.6 grams of carbohydrate.
So really, you could only get away with, if
you only ate that as your carbohydrate, you're
only going to get away with maybe two and
a half apples a day.
A lot of people, because they eat other things,
and there's a little bit of carbohydrate in
cheese and nuts and things like that, the
apples are going to blow them way out of ketosis.
I know I recommend apples in my book, so again,
I am very willing to change my ideas when
I test out new theories.
I'm not recommending apples any more, especially
if you're trying to lose weight.
Maybe if you're maintaining weight, you can
definitely have them.
One thing I want to talk about apples, is
that it has just a tiny bit of fiber, so that
means that 19 grams of the total 25 grams
are completely sugar.
It's a lot of sugar.
It's a tremendous amount of sugar.
Let's get to celery.
Check how many carbohydrates are in celery.
1.2 grams, and there's .6 grams of fiber,
so we're left with .6 grams of total carbohydrates,
net carbohydrates.
That's like half a gram of carbohydrate.
In other words, you can eat a lot of celery
and you don't have to worry about anything.
There's actually no dietary sugar in celery.
All right, good.
You guys are responsive.
You have a lot of good comments here.
I'll get to those.
Hang in there.
Obviously there's sour apples and there's
sweet apples but I think, I didn't check on
the amount of sugar in the sour apples, but
I'm sure it's not that low compared to where
we're going with this.
Here's the thing.
We must starve the body of sugar.
That's a constant.
We're going to keep our carbs very low.
The next topic we're going to talk about is
protein.
Protein is needed for the raw material for
ligaments, muscles, tendons, enzymes, hormones,
bones, cholesterol transportation, like good
and better cholesterol.
You have high density lipo proteins.
Basically, cholesterol has a protein shuttle
that moves it around.
The problem with protein is we need some,
but we don't want too much.
The reason for that is that too much can trigger
insulin.
That's the problem.
Because we don't shed off that much protein
each day.
Protein is used mainly for structural type
things, to replace the damaged parts.
I know people that when they try to beef up
and get bigger at the gym, they eat more protein,
what's going to happen, they're going to strain
their livers and their kidneys, so it's not
good advice.
We want to adjust the protein to the person.
To their size, and to their adrenal health.
The adrenal puts a person in, called a counterblock
state.
It breaks down protein a lot faster, especially
in the quadriceps muscles in your legs and
your gluteus maximus, which is your butt muscle.
Both of those muscles can break down if you
have adrenal stress, so you need a little
bit more protein, but overall we're not doing
a lot of protein.
I would say anywhere between three and six
ounces of protein per meal is perfect.
When you talk about the Atkins diet, they're
talking about doing a lot more protein.
We're not talking about, ketosis is not a
lot of protein.
It's a moderate amount of protein.
We're going to keep that as a constant.
We keep our carbs down and our proteins at
a constant.
So now, what's the last variable?
You got it.
Fat.
I know we've been taught that if you eat fat,
you get fat, it's very bad, blah blah blah
blah blah.
Let me just give you some date on what fat
really will do when you consume the right
amount.
The first thing that it won't do is it will
not raise your insulin, because fat is neutral
with insulin.
That's one thing.
The second thing is that when you start consuming
the right type of fats, you're going to need
that to satisfy the brain for the fat-soluble
vitamins that most vegetarians and other people
are deficient in.
When you eat your vegetables, even kale, people
will say, I eat spinach and I eat kale and
it's loaded with vitamin A, that's true.
But it's a precursor to vitamin A. It's not
the active form.
You need animal fats to get the active, available
form of the fats out of the vitamins, like
vitamin A. Where do you get vitamin A?
In butter.
Grass-fed butter.
Kerrygold butter is the best.
Carrots provide the precursor that convert
into the active form, but you really, if your
system is good, you only convert about five
percent of that so you'd have to eat a lot
of vegetables to get your fats out of vitamins
and so people that are eating a lot of vegetables
and hardly any fat, they dry out.
The skin dries out.
We need those fats out of vitamins.
One thing to help you when you eat vegetables
to get more fats out of vitamins, out of that
vegetable, is to consume fat with your vegetables,
like butter.
Very smart thing to do.
The goal of ketosis goes beyond just weight
loss, but here's what we want to do when you
get on the ketosis.
We want you to not just burn the fat that
you're eating, which you will, but we want
you to tap into your reserves.
That is the only way you're going to do it,
is if you cut the carbs down.
Okay?
You will have to adjust the amount of fats
to your activity level.
There is something of, certain people burn
more calories than others and some people
are going to need a little bit more fat.
If you're sedentary and you have a very poor
metabolism, you might not be able to have
the amount of fats of someone 18.
But you can definitely have some to satisfy
your body and run the machine a lot better.
So that's another variable that we have to
adjust as we go through this.
Why do we need fat to burn fat?
That's an interesting question.
First of all, the body considers fat as the
last-stored ditch effort of survival, and
so if you cut the fat away your body will
start holding on to fat more dearly.
When you start putting that fat back, it will
feel a lot safer to be able to let some of
it go, because again it's a survival mechanism.
If you have no dietary fats, you starve the
body of not only the ketones but the structural
types of fats that you need to surround all
the cells of your body, to surround all the
nerve endings, because all your nerves are
surrounded with myelin sheath, that's fat,
and your brain is mostly fat, so you actually
starve some of the structural fats and you
end up having a lot of health problems with
the immune system.
I think it was Pritikin, he had a lot of health
problems, I think he committed suicide, I
think it probably affected his whole mood
when you cut your fats was down.
It's very dangerous to have a very low-fat
diet.
It's much healthier to have the healthy fats.
I've been doing the fats forever, and I consume
a tremendous amount of fats.
If you do a low-carb, low-fat and high-protein
diet, you will then spike that insulin because
high protein stimulates insulin.
It stresses the kidneys and liver.
So the person will start feeling more bloated.
They'll get back pain a little bit higher
up.
That's the stress on the kidney.
If you do a low-carb, low-fat, low protein,
there's not enough fats to stimulate the ketosis
and so your body because of the low protein,
low fat, will have a tendency to go after
structural proteins of your body, so it starts
to break down more protein.
Really, the ideal, when you look at it from
all different sides, the ideal situation is
to have about five percent of the total calories
being carbohydrate, 20 to 25 percent being
protein, and the rest being fat.
Then you just have adjust the quantities.
Really eating fat keeps the body out of stress.
You don't have those danger signals.
In fact, think about what sugar metabolism
is.
Eating sugar puts your body in the state of
fight or flight mode, all the time, because
it's a sudden burst of quick energy that keeps
dropping blood sugars up and down, up and
down.
That's stress.
It's going to activate cortisol, that's that
stress hormone.
Where do you get your vitamin A, vitamin D,
vitamin E, K2?
You get vitamin A from the grass-fed butter.
You also will get it from the cod liver oil.
Vitamin D from the sun, cod liver oil again,
fish oils, grass-fed butter and egg yolks
are loaded with vitamin D. Vitamin E you can
get from butter again, but you can also get
it from nuts and seeds and certain oils.
The other one I want to talk about is vitamin
K2.
Vitamin K2 is one of the most important vitamins
for a lot of health problems, specifically
making your arteries elastic, so it's really
good for blood pressure.
It's good to clean out the calcium buildup
in your arteries and your joints.
That's in grass-fed beef, butter and cheese.
So you want that grass-fed cow.
Very important.
It's kind of a recently discovered vitamin,
but it makes sense now that putting your body
in ketosis would naturally have you gravitate
to more of these fatty foods that have the
vitamins that you've been missing this whole
time.
I always ask people that are vegetarians,
I says, "Where do you get your vitamin K2?"
You could get it from a vegetarian source,
it's called natto.
But where do you get all your vitamin A?
And where do you get your other fats out of
the vitamins?
It's just something to consider.
It's very difficult to get into ketosis if
you're vegetarian.
I have nothing against trying to do that,
but most vegetarians are grainaterians.
They do the grains and the breads and the
pastas.
Now, what types of fats are healthy?
That is the question.
The types of fats that are low stress to the
liver and don't stress the gall bladder are
the medium chain fats, medium chain triglycerides.
What does that mean?
That means that those fats that you would
consume, like grass-fed butter, that's a medium
chain triglyceride.
Coconut butter is a, called MCT, medium chain
triglyceride.
Olive oil is good, grass-fed cheese, pasture
raised eggs, where chickens go out there and
can go and eat grass.
Grass-fed beef, pasture raised chickens, those
are the ones that you're going to have to
eat.
Believe it or not, grass-fed beef has a really
good type of fat.
It's called a mono-unsaturated fat, that bypasses
your liver and it's used just for energy.
I feel really good when I do that, but you
don't want to consume the lean beef.
You want to have the fattier beef.
You don't want to have the chicken with the
skin off.
You want that skin.
It's exactly opposite of what we've been taught.
Ketones provide three times as much energy,
so you'll find that your brain just has more
energy.
You actually need a little bit less sleep
if you do this and it's very stable on your
blood sugar so you don't get so moody.
So many people have anxiety.
It's just their blood sugar.
Especially if they're waking up in the middle
of the night having anxiety.
Ketones are only made, and I'm not talking
about diabetes, but ketones, called nutritional
ketosis, only occurs when the body is starving
of carbohydrates.
That's what you have to do.
There's some other benefits too that I want
to talk about with your gut.
A lot of people get swelling in their gut
when they have just a little bit of fruit
and beans and some other grains, it just tears
them up.
When they start going more fat, their entire
digestive system does wonderful.
I'll never forget, I was living on grains,
trying to be a vegetarian when I was 28, and
then one day I was in California, I was driving
down the street, and I see this huge building.
It says, The Health House.
It's this yellow building.
I said, "Honey, let's go in there.
Let's see what they have.
Maybe they can help me."
This old-time weight lifter guy was selling
vitamins and things, and he brought me in
the back and he gave me some raw milk and
he said here, eat this beef, whatever, and
that was in the morning and I ate that and
I felt so amazingly good.
So I started having that for breakfast, and
I do much much better and I cut the cereal
out.
I used to be the epitome of the junk-food
junkie.
I used to eat the muffins, huge muffins, Life
cereal, I would do that.
I would live on sugar.
But coming back to my point was that your
gut could do very well on fats.
In fact, the microbes in your gut primarily
live on something called butyric acid, and
yes, that does come from the breakdown of
eating vegetables, but it also comes from
butter.
That's the main source to feed your microbes.
The other source, smaller source of something
that feeds your microbes would be acetic acid,
and that is in apple cider vinegar.
Apple cider vinegar is a really good thing.
A teaspoon in some water and as you drink
that with your lemon, forget the cranberry,
but just drink that through the day, that
will really help you in shrinking your stomach.
Now I want to talk about beef, for example.
Let's say a hamburger without the bun.
How much carbohydrate is in the hamburger?
Zero.
How much fat is in there?
24 percent of that hamburger is fat.
Guess how much protein?
30 percent.
So we got, it's almost half fat and half protein.
When I say you need 60 percent of your diet
fat, I'm talking about a lot of the protein
sources that you're eating have a tremendous
amount of fat already.
We're not talking about thinking that piece
of meat, for example, is pure protein and
you have to eat all this lard.
I'm not talking about that.
A lot of the proteins that you already eat
are loaded with a certain percentage of fat.
There's a study that I'm going to send you.
It's called the long term effects of a ketogenic
diet in obese patients.
This is what it says.
This is experimental clinical cardiology.
Says, "The administration of a ketogenic diet
for relatively longer periods of time did
not produce any significant side effects in
patients.
It's safe to use for longer periods."
You know, they're not going to admit this
because who wants to be wrong, right?
All right, so, I also, I wish I could show
you this picture.
Let me see if I can do that now.
Let's see if that screen share ... No.
It doesn't work.
That's fine.
I have these new keto bombs I want to share
with you.
It's an amazing recipe.
In fact, I will send, let me see if I can
send that right now.
Some of you have already clicked on and went
to drberg.com fat burning diets.
Let me just see if I can send that to you
here.
Yeah, maybe I can.
I think that went to everyone.
Let me see if I can, oh, to everyone.
Here we go.
To everyone.
Okay.
I'll paste it in there, boom.
Now everyone should get this link, and you
could look at this later, not right now, but
if you go in there, a lot of you already went
in there but I added some new things.
I added these new keto bombs that are just
amazingly delicious.
I give you the recipe and you can make them
as a base and you can put all sorts of things
in there to make them interesting with nuts
and they're delicious and they're very healthy.
It's one of the best treats that you can eat,
and I'm going through quite a few of those
little guys.
I also have in here kind of a general eating
plan that I'm going to recommend for you,
but the other thing I want to mention is that
... Yes.
I want to answer a question.
Yes, it will be later available on YouTube.
Here's the thing that I wanted to mention.
That the kale recipe, the kale shake recipe
that I've been recommending, I'm changing
that recipe and I'm actually going to put
it in a booklet and just get it out there.
It'll be on my website, but here's the thing
that I wanted to mention about that, is that
I'm taking out the fruit and I'm putting in
there something called liquid stevia.
Very flavored, with two tablespoons of coconut
oil.
You blend it up, I swear, it tastes just like
a kale shake.
It's amazing, and you don't really need the
berries.
That would be something you can do on a regular
basis.
I have a whole week of foods that I'm going
to get to your guys, and then I have the new
kale shake recipe and how to make it, and
there's a couple other things that you need
to think about when you to this ketosis eating
plan.
One is that some people are going to have
to adapt to ketosis, and that adaptation takes
anywhere between three days to two weeks but
think about, it could probably take you more
than two weeks to get into a good state.
Your body has to adapt to it, it has to make
new enzymes, it has to produce more bile,
and if you have any liver or gall bladder
issues you may need to add bile in there.
A lot of you are taking my gall bladder formula,
but I want to let you know I changed the formula
just recently.
The new formula, I added something called
pancreatin to the gall bladder formula.
Not only does it have the bile for the gall
bladder support and the stomach enzymes, but
now we have the ultimate pancreatic enzymes,
especially lipase.
Lipase is the main enzymes to digest lipids
or fats, so the reason I put that in there
is because I realized that when people take
the bile and it breaks down the fat, it doesn't
break it all the way down to the smallest
level.
They need the lipase to take it all the way
down to complete, full digestion so the new
gall bladder formula has all three main component
parts so it handles all parts of the digestion.
That's kind of something that a lot of people
take when they are doing more fats.
The other thing you want to think about when
you do this is that you're going to have to
increase your sea salt when you do this, because
carbohydrates store so much sugar and when
you actually eating them, you dump all the
sugar and you dump some of the electrolytes,
and if you don't add the sea salt back into
the diet you might be a little dizzy, headachy,
lethargy, fatigue, all those symptoms.
I also recommend doing a calcium/magnesium
before bed.
You can get calcium citrate, magnesium citrate
and just take it before bed, because calcium/magnesium
is going to be a little bit more important
now if you're doing more fat and low carbs.
Unless you have too much calcium, which is
probably not the case.
We want to look at several things.
We want to make sure that the minerals are
in there, that we can digest some of these
fats, we want to keep the constant low carbohydrate,
moderate protein, and higher fats.
Now we're going to adjust the fats for your
tolerance, for your digestion and for your
weight loss.
If you are not active, obviously you're not
going to have as many fats as I do.
But if you're exercising, you can get away
with more fats.
Now that your body is getting more in ketosis,
you're not going to crave anything anymore,
you're not going to be as hungry, so you're
not going to have the appetite you had before.
It's going to be much better to do this and
let's say, before you go to bed just take
one of those keto snacks and you're good to
go.
What I want to do, I want to answer some questions.
Someone asked about milk.
Milk is high in protein, but it has lactose.
You might want to look on the label and see
how many net carbohydrates, because I don't
think there's a lot of fiber in that milk,
so you want to end up with no more than 50
net carbohydrates per day, so you might want
to do a little calculation on that.
What are the optimum numbers for ketosis?
As far as what numbers?
When you test your urine for ketosis?
You can get a keto strip and urinate and see
if you're in strong ketosis or not, but don't
be discouraged if you don't get into ketosis
right away.
It might take two weeks, or four weeks.
Some people get constipation.
They might need a little bit of bile support,
and that's in the gall bladder formula.
That lubricates the colon and add a little
more sea salt to add more fluid and water
so you don't dry out.
That should handle those symptoms.
If you don't have a gall bladder, you definitely
need some support in that area, because where's
the bile coming from?
Strictly down your liver.
You're going to have to take bile as extract
with each meal because you don't have enough,
and you won't be able to pull in the fats
out of vitamins that you need, you'll end
up with dry skin.
Someone asked about alcohol.
Alcohol is out.
You can't do alcohol, I'm sorry, because it's
going to bump you out of ketosis for probably
a good week.
If you're willing to do that, you can do it.
Someone asked about kefir.
There is a type of kefir that you can use
that is non-lactate, so that's no sugar.
Lactate is milk sugar, so I think you can
get away with that.
One of the great ingredients in this keto
bomb is cream cheese, organic cream cheese.
Oh my gosh, it makes the cookies so amazing.
Eggs, that depends on your size.
I do four eggs and cheese in the morning every
single morning.
My wife can't do more than two eggs, she can't
do it.
So it really depends on how many that you,
how big you are and your appetite.
Turkey bacon?
I don't recommend it because it's too lean.
You actually need a good source of bacon that
has no nitrates and hormone free.
That's what I'm going to recommend.
Unless you want the turkey bacon just for
your protein.
There's a lot of questions coming in here.
If you're pregnant and nursing, that's something
I'm not going to recommend on line here because
I don't want to take responsibility.
I think what I would do is I would check with
your doctor and see if it's okay, but just
make sure that ... If you take an infant,
breast milk is the ultimate ketose diet because
you're getting all these fats.
An infant used ketones in a developing brain.
That's what they use.
Diet soda?
Well, it's better than sugar but it's not
the greatest.
What I do is I take Pellegrino, this stuff
right here, Pellegrino, I go through tons
of them.
I put about five drops of flavored root beer
or cola stevia, and it tastes like a soda.
I love it.
Okay.
Pam asked, can I skip a meal if I'm not hungry?
Absolutely.
See, this is the thing.
You're going to find that your appetite's
going to go down, you're not going to be as
hungry, then don't eat.
You don't need to.
It's not going to actually help you.
And you'll do fine, because you're actually
eating denser calorie foods and you're going
to have enough nutrients and you can tap into
more fat if you do that.
Someone asked about avocados.
Wonderful.
Wonderful fat, I love it.
Someone asked about xylitol.
That's my sugar, that I have.
Xylitol is a great birchbark type of sweetener,
it's way better than the other ones.
Some of the vegetarian chocolate chips use
maltitol.
Don't buy them with maltitol.
You can do with mannitol if you want.
I like the stevia.
But maltitol, I don't recommend it.
I don't recommend honey, either.
Coffee, if you have a small amount of coffee
with xylitol, not any more of that, it's not
going to be a big problem.
Kidney disease.
If you have kidney disease, that's another,
I'm not going to answer that online because
someone's going to say, "Oh, yeah, Dr. Berg
..." That's something like a one on one question,
but I will say that people with kidney disease
do not do well with a lot of protein, but
they do really well on some fats.
They do very well.
In fact, I would love to do a research project,
go down to the local dialysis unit and just
put everyone on the right eating plan.
I bet you I would see incredible things.
But they're not going to let me do that.
What about the adrenal?
Someone's asking about the adrenal.
It's a really good program for the adrenal,
but you just have to have a little bit more
protein.
More protein.
The problem with some people, if they're real,
have severe blood sugar issues, have severe
hypoglycemic, they might have the transition
phase that's a little more gradual, so you
may have to add maybe some fruit into that
mix for a little bit.
Out of all, oh, you might want to mute your
mike, Judy.
Out of all the sweet things, there's level
of damaging sweet fruits.
If we have potatoes and things like that versus
fruit, fruit is much better even though it's
sweet, and the reason for that, the fructose
has a different pathway than starches.
Fructose does not necessarily spike insulin.
It does create fat in the liver, but it doesn't
jack up insulin as much as some of these starches.
So if someone was a diabetic and they had
low blood sugar, don't take the glucose tablets,
take some fruit.
Not orange juice, but actual fruit.
Does the diet affect hypo-thyroidism and adrenal
fatigue?
It probably would improve both conditions,
but hypo-thyroid is usually coming secondary
from estrogen dominance or a gall bladder/liver
problem.
You can watch that video that I created on
that.
Nutritional yeast is totally fine, because
that'll give you the B vitamins that you need.
Type I diabetics need to do this.
It'll take the stress off the pancreas and
really help them stabilize the blood sugars.
The only thing you have to do is you have
to make sure your greens are very high.
So in this eating plan, where I get all my
vitamins and minerals is from the greens.
My salads are huge.
I'm going a lot of green vegetable, but I
eat the fiber.
I don't just juice everything.
I want the nutrients, I want some of the fiber
in there.
These are coming through.
It says Dr. Gregg doesn't agree with extracting
fiber from the carbs.
He says carbs are carbs.
Here's the thing.
You don't want to just look at the net carb.
You want to see if there's actual sugars in
there and you want to use judgment.
Obviously if it's a vegetable, you don't really
have to worry about it so much.
If it's some box food, you do.
There's certain things that you know that
are high glycemic, you're going to have to
avoid them.
Make sure that your xylitol, that's a good
point, Lynn, is from birchbark, not from corn.
Yes.
Wheat grass juice powder is totally fine to
consume because it's, there's not a lot of
sugar in that and it's a tremendous amount
of concentrated green juice that will give
you a lot of nutrition.
Almond butter is good, unsweetened peanut
butter is good unless you have allergies.
Someone says, will I ever be able to eat fruit
again?
Yeah, you will.
Once you lose the weight, then you can stick
in the fruits more as a maintenance because
you're going to be able to get away with more
carbohydrate the more you do this.
You're basically fixing your pancreas, you're
fixing your liver when you do this, because
you're taking all the stress off the pancreas
that's been working so hard, so it starts
to come back and recover.
It's a wonderful thing to do for your body.
Kombucha tea?
You want to get the one with two grams of
sugar and make sure that you don't have any
more than that.
Some of them have a lot more sugar.
You just have to look at labels.
Cruciferous vegetables, if you can't do those,
that's fine.
Do spinach.
Do leafy greens.
Totally fine.
Let me just grab this right here.
There's four more minutes.
Someone mentioned ketosis for polycystic ovarian
syndrome, absolutely.
It would be the thing that I think would help
you more than anything.
Boy, you guys ask a lot of questions.
These flowing through so fast.
How do you gain muscle on ketosis?
Well, you're going to get leaner, you're going
to burn fat, you don't need a lot of protein
to build muscle.
You need exercise, but you need to keep the
insulin low so you don't get that conversion
to the fatty tissue.
I have lots of people who lost tremendous
amount of weight doing this, and they were
very stubborn before, this is what they really
needed.
You have to take it one step further.
I want to send everyone a link to something
that I want to ask you.
A lot of you are on my email list, a lot of
you watch my videos and you know that I give
a lot of free stuff out.
I hope you appreciate that.
What I'm going to ask from you in exchange
tonight is to give me an unbiased review.
That's all I want in exchange, I want a review.
I'm going to send you a link to this review
site, you just type in a review, tell me what's
your experience with my information, what
you think about me, whatever.
Be honest and say whatever you want to say,
but then you'll get an email, probably tomorrow
morning, that will tell you to cut and paste
that review onto either Google Plus or another
site, and I'd really appreciate that is you
would do that for me.
I'm going to continue to give you guys a lot
of good content but in exchange I would really
appreciate it if you could give me a review.
I sent you the link, and you can do that after
we're done.
I want to thank you in advance for that.
Someone just asked me a question, I got to
go back, I just quickly saw that, oh, you're
welcome.
Thank you.
Neuropathy.
Peripheral neuropathy is purely high sugar
in the blood, so when you do this eating plan,
your sugars will be so much better it'll take
the pressure off the destruction of the myelin
sheath and it will greatly improve the peripheral
neuropathy.
But you're going to have to add nutritional
yeast to add those B vitamins to be able to
feed the deficiencies that you're creating
by all this insulin.
Okay.
Someone said, but I can't buy and afford everything
in the world.
Well, here's the thing.
You don't have to spend a lot of money on
a ketosis diet.
You could make these keto bombs in bulk.
You're not eating as much food.
You can make the most incredible ice cream,
I'm going to create some videos on how to
make some ice cream that is totally legal,
and you can do that, and it's not expensive.
You make a whole bunch and you freeze it.
There is a way to do it.
How many carbs can I have per day?
I would say no more than 50 carbs a day, but
don't worry about salads.
You're not going to get a lot of carbs from
them.
But even ... I'm 50, and my skin keeps getting
better and better the more I do this.
I do take a lot of fat-soluble vitamins, I
use the gall bladder formula to emulsify,
so I'm constantly pushing fats into my system
and I don't have dry skin or anything like
that.
Okay, if you didn't get the email that I sent
to everyone, I'll send it one more time, but
I'll just send it to your email right now,
actually.
It should be going right now, so if you don't
get an email, I sent it to you, and if you
still don't get an email, do me a favor.
Tomorrow, go to my Google Plus page and do
a review on Google Plus.
I would appreciate that very much.
I want to keep it to an hour, I do these monthly,
I'm going to be asking for more ideas to talk
about, but I hope you got some tips.
I'll be doing more seminars.
I really appreciate the attention and all
the questions, and yes, I will send you that
recipe, George, for ice cream and the keto
bombs.
I'm going to be checking out now, so I want
to thank you guys for coming out and thank
you, Judy, for being there, to be someone
I could relay stuff back and forth.
This video will be recorded on my YouTube
channel, which is, you could find that by
typing in Dr. Berg, and I know you guys are
just downloaded all these questions.
I'm not going to be able to get to all of
them but I want to thank you guys and have
a great evening.
See you next time.